H
REPUBLICANS TAKING CONTROL OF
THE HOUSE IN JANUARY.
>> ALL, RIGHT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
CNN IS LEARNING THAT FORMER
VICE PRESIDENT MIKE PENCE IS
OPEN TO DISCUSSING A POSSIBLE
AGREEMENT WITH THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT.
THEY ARE SEEKING HIS TESTIMONY
IN A CRIMINAL INVESTIGATION.
AND EFFORTS BY FORMER PRESIDENT
TRUMP AND HIS ALLIES TO STOP
THE TRANSFER OF POWER AFTER THE
2020 ELECTION.
CNN SENIOR LEGAL ANALYST AND
FORMER FEDERAL PROSECUTOR ELIE
HONIG IS WITH US NOW.
THAT IS FASCINATING THAT THE
FORMER VICE PRESIDENT MIGHT GET
INTO A CONVERSATION WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE ABOUT ALL
THIS.
CAN THEY FORCE HIM IF HE
REFUSES?
>> YES, THEY CAN FOR SOME OF
YOUR FUSES.
I THINK FOR THAT REASON, MIKE
PENCE MIGHT WORK OUT SOME
AGREEMENT, WHERE HE TESTIFIED
IN FRONT OF A GRAND JURY.
OR PERHAPS JUST GIVES AN
INTERVIEW TO DOJ.
IT'S IMPORTANT TO UNDERSTAND.
HERE WE ARE IN THE REALM OF THE
JANUARY SIX COMMITTEE AND
CONGRESS AND CONGRESSIONAL
SUBPOENAS AND CONGRESSIONAL
REQUESTS FOR INFORMATION.
WE ARE TALKING ABOUT A CRIMINAL
INVESTIGATION BEING CARRIED OUT
BY THE U.S. DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE.
AND IF YOU THINK BACK TO THE
JANUARY SIX INVESTIGATION, WE
SAW PLENTY OF PEOPLE INCLUDING
MIKE PENCE HIMSELF, SORT OF
CASUALLY BRUSH OFF THE
COMMITTEE AND NOTHING HAPPENED.
IT DOESN'T WORK THAT WAY WHEN
YOU ARE IN FRONT OF DOJ AND A
GRAND JURY.
THEY CAN COMPEL YOU TO COME
FORWARD AND TESTIFY IF YOU
DON'T WANT TO, IF YOU DON'T
AGREE TO.
AND THE ARGUMENTS THAT MIKE
PENCE MADE REGARDING JANUARY
6TH, WELL, HE SAID FIRST OF ALL,
THERE'S A SEPARATION OF POWERS
PROBLEM WITH THE FORMER VICE
PRESIDENT TESTIFYING IN FRONT
OF CONGRESS.
THAT DOES NOT APPLY HERE.
WE ARE TALKING ABOUT THE
EXECUTIVE BRANCH.
DOJ.
AND THERE COULD BE AN EXECUTIVE
PRIVILEGE ISSUE.
THAT MAY MEAN THAT THERE IS
STILL PLENTY OF TOPICS ON WHICH
MIKE PENCE CAN TESTIFY.
I DON'T THINK EXECUTIVE
PRIVILEGE WILL HOLD HERE.
DOJ HAS THE UPPERHAND.
AND I THINK MIKE PENCE WILL
TALK TO THEM.
>> WHAT DOES IT SAY ABOUT THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT STRATEGY
HERE?
>> IT TELLS US THAT THEY ARE
NOW LOOKING AT THE TOP OF THE
FOOD CHAIN.
AT THE TOP OF THE POWER
HIERARCHY.
IT HAS TAKEN SOME TIME FOR THEM
TO GET THERE.
I THINK THAT'S A CRITICISM.
WE DO KNOW THAT DOJ NOW IS
FOCUSED SQUARELY ON DONALD
TRUMP.
IN FACT, MERRICK GARLAND, THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL, ANNOUNCED THE
SPECIAL COUNSEL A WEEK AGO.
THAT WAS THE FIRST TIME DOJ
SPECIFICALLY ACKNOWLEDGED THAT
THEY ARE FOCUSED ON DONALD
TRUMP HIMSELF.
BUT AGAIN, HERE WE ARE, THE END
OF 2022, AND DOJ IS FINALLY
GETTING AROUND TO TALKING TO
MIKE PENCE.
I DON'T SEE WHY THEY COULD'VE
DONE THIS IN EARLIER --
THEY FOREIGN LEE FOCUSED ON THE
TOP.
>> THIS IS ALSO FASCINATING.
THIS WEEK, A FORMER APPEALS
COURT --
CHALLENGE FOR THE SPECIAL
MASTER, APPOINTED TO --
A RULING COULD COME ANY TIME.
THAT RULING, I IMAGINE, WILL BE
VERY IMPORTANT AND ALL OF THIS.
>> IT WILL.
AND IT SURE LOOKS LIKE THE 11TH
CIRCUIT BOARD OF APPEALS WILL
SIDE WITH THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT AND AGAINST ALL
TRUMP.
AND PUT AN END TO THE SPECIAL
MASTER A FEW.
LOOKING AT THAT ARGUMENT, THE
THREE JUDGE COURT OF APPEALS
PANEL WAS QUITE SKEPTICAL
TOWARDS THE RATIONALE THAT
DONALD TRUMP'S LAWYERS WERE
ARGUING.
I THINK HIS LAWYERS ACTUALLY
MISHANDLED THAT ARGUMENT.
THEY COULD'VE MADE A VERY
STRAIGHTFORWARD ARGUMENT.
WE HAVE A SPECIAL MASTER.
A PERSON WHO BOTH SIDES HAVE
AGREED TO.
ALL WE ARE ASKING IS THAT HE
PROTECTS OUR PRIVILEGES.
INSTEAD, THEY WENT BEYOND, THAT
AND SAID THOSE DOCUMENTS BELONG
TO DONALD TRUMP.
THERE IS PROPERTY.
HE GETS TO KEEP THEM.
SOMETIMES, LAWYERS MAKE THAT
MISTAKE.
THEY ARGUE MORE THAN THEY NEED
IN ORDER TO PREVAIL ON THE
ISSUE.
WE COULD HEAR ANY DAY.
IF THIS GOES IN DOJ'S FAVOR,
THEN IT WILL PUT AN END TO THE
SPECIAL MASTER RULING.